anti-racism campaigners have set their
sights on the leading art gallery in
britain over a colonial era
mural that does show an enslaved black
child
tate britain now accept that the work is
offensive
the chair of the ethics committee noted
that members were unequivocal in their
view that the
imagery of the work is offensive
trustees discuss the need to acknowledge
the strength of
feeling around the mural and the harm
that its imagery has caused
well the work which does cover the wall
of a gallery restaurant is called the
expedition in pursuit of rare meats it
is by rex whistler
and shows a hunting expedition
characters in the piece do include a
captured black boy
being led with a chain around his neck
campaigners want to remove though
or the restaurant closed and the gallery
does say it is considering
how to respond
we are taking this time to consult
internally and externally
on the future of the room and the mural
and we will keep the public informed of
future plans
well it has polarized opinion between
those who want the mural to stay
and those who call it an unacceptable
carryover from britain's colonial past
we put the issue up for debate
we need to debate and leave these things
where they are so people can understand
history and understand how far we have
come
from from these images that they may now
yeah find offensive under the uh
situation if you're just going to hide
things away then you're never going to
educate people it's part of
british history but it's also part of
black history i think that's uh what
you're looking at
is a deeply offensive artwork placed in
one of the most predictive
predecess art galleries in the country
post black lives matter the whole
paradigm shift in thinking
is that what was informally acceptable
what used to be acceptable
is now no longer acceptable i think that
you can
move the mural to some sort of museum of
colonialism or british shame and you can
provide the education context there
uh but to have the uh soup song of
slavery while you're eating your fight
grot
in the premier arts establishment of the
country
it can be moved and it can be placed in
its proper educational context
but he's certainly not in a public space
uh in uh
the prestigious art gallery well just to
keep saying it's british colonialism
is actually misleading and it's actually
false because you're misleading
people of black history and the issue of
blm
blm is a left-wing marxist political
party it's a registered political party
now
so it's the actual movement for black
lives
has lost its momentum as being any
credibility
but let's educate people about the
entire history of the slave
but don't hide the fact that black
african tribes
were complicit in it well before
europeans got there and it wasn't just
british colonialism
can we just be absolutely clear because
you know i wouldn't want the
uh viewers to be misled that chattel
slavery
chance atlantic chapel slavery wasn't
the periodic enslavement of warring
tribes that could be released on the
negotiation
between different villages it was the
most brutal
long-lasting exploitation probably one
of the greatest crimes in human history
i saw over 50 million africans exported
from west africa
and the interior what lee wants to do is
just hide history away
so senator defends everybody in that
time
in 1977. i'm not i want to hide anything
away i want to put it in a
history and a museum of colonialism and
slavery that puts it in its proper
context
and you my friend would be the first
customer to get educated
because your ignorance is so profound
has to be absolutely shocking